décembre 2014
à peine quatre mois après la fin d'une
guerre brutale dans la bande de gaza les
forces du hamas descendait dans les rues
de la capitale
il soulignait ainsi le 27ème
anniversaire de la création du parti
la branche armée est considéré comme un
groupe terroriste par israël les états
unis le canada et l'union européenne
mais pour ses partisans le hamas est
plutôt un mouvement légitime de
résistance à l'occupation israélienne
la démonstration de force de ces
brigades al qassam se voulait imposante
le message clair le hamas a gagné la
dernière guerre la population de la
bande de gaza a payé le prix fort de ce
que la hamas revendique comme une
victoire sur l'armée israélienne plus de
2100 morts palestiniens une majorité
d'entre deux civils selon les nations
unies dont près de 500 enfants 66
soldats ici civils israéliens et un
travailleur agricole thaïlandais sont
aussi morts pendant l'opération
militaire baptisée bordure protectrice
la victoire affirme le hamas ne se
comptent pas en termes de victimes à
charles avérera tab et hélène quand un
peuple une occupation refuse de céder
face à l'occupant on peut considérer
qu'il en sort gagnant web al-wadi à lui
vous dira qu'il n'a rien gagné mais
plutôt tout perdu pendant la guerre son
fils adli était emprisonné depuis 2010
par le hamas accusé de collaboration
avec l'ennemi
la semaine des hommes cagoulés sont
venus à la prison de gaza
ils ont pris mon fils avec d'autres
membres du fatah ils les ont exécutés de
manière atroce
adam
c'était en août dernier à la sortie de
la grande prière du vendredi devant la
mosquée de gaza
en pleine guerre jamais aimé mon fils
veut plus de 100 balles d'un corps plus
d'une centaine en entrevue il n'ya rien
moussa du bureau politique du hamas a
réfuté que ce gouvernement est ordonné
lés assassinats
il y à une enquête sur ces cas et s'il
est coupable appartiennent au hamas ils
seront punis
nous cherchons à savoir s'ils font
partie du hamas mais les résultats de
cette enquête ne seront jamais rendu
public
il en va de l'unité du peuple
palestinien affirmé yahia moussa
moodagent le groupe armé état islamique
a dû apprendre de ces gens-là étudier
leurs méthodes imaginez ils étaient 31
lui tirer dessus avec des mitrailleurs
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils avaient peur
qu'ils reviennent en vie webb refuse de
condamner l'ensemble du mouvement hamas
mais les gazaouis sont gouvernés par la
peur dit il
dix membres du fatah le parti du
président de l'autorité palestinienne
mahmoud abbas et le principal rival du
hamas
il croit que son fils assassiné a servi
d'exemple sous les bombes l'été dernier
la population de gaza s'est ralliée
quasi unanimement derrière le hamas les
critiques se faisait rare mais selon un
sondage mené en mars dernier dans la
bande de gaza seulement 30% de la
population croit que le hamas a remporté
la guerre l'été dernier qui plus est à
peine 22% affirmé vouloir voter de
nouveau pour eux le mécontentement est
nourri par la destruction colossal des
infrastructures et une reconstruction
qui tarde à se matérialiser la
population a accès à l'électricité que
de six à sept heures par jour au mieux
l'eau potable se fait rare le chômage
selon la banque mondiale atteint les 44
% probablement le taux le plus élevé au
monde
les manifestations sont pourtant
exceptionnel ici ces images ont été
filmées lors d'une des rares
démonstration publique des gazaouis
inspirés par les soulèvements populaires
du printemps arabe
ils ont eu le moment venu d'exiger la
réconciliation des différentes factions
politiques ennemis avec des centaines de
concitoyens
ça m'a aidé descendus dans la rue pour
réclamer la fin des divisions entre le
hamas et le fatah brive et année on
croyait que le premier pas vers la fin
de l'occupation et est cesser nos
divisions internes
nous avons le même ennemi c'est
l'occupation israélienne seul mot
d'ordre de la manifestation
denis porter le drapeau palestinien et
parler de ce qui vous préoccupe une
services de sécurité du hamas ne
l'entendait pas de la sorte à cet art le
service de sécurité du hamas nous a
attaqués sans prévenir
j'ai été poignardé dans le dos je
n'imaginais pas qu'on s'en prenne à moi
puisque je suis une femme ce qu'elle
réclamait comme une majorité de
palestiniens
l'unification des partis le hamas et le
fatah ont fini par le promettre en juin
dernier les frères ennemis devait former
un gouvernement d'unité nationale mais
c'est une réconciliation qui tout sauf
concrètes et qui vient trop tard
je ne peux plus leur faire confiance en
fait je les blâme car ce sont eux qui
nous ont amenés lagache responsable de
la guerre ou pas le hamas et par la
relève
ils ont entre 12 et 18 ans exercices
physiques et discipline de rang pour les
plus jeunes
maniement des armes pour les
adolescentes voilà les activités au menu
dans ce camp de jour annuelle organisée
par le hamas
ceux là ont tous pris part aux plus
récentes c'est quand après en avoir
entendu parler à la mosquée du quartier
nos combattants ceux qui n'ont pas
d'armes
les femmes des enfants des vieillards on
ne peut pas être de bons voisins soit
ils quittent nos terres et nous vivront
en paix soit nous allons mourir en
martyr dans la rue mandar des hameaux
tsheri
au cours de leur courte vie ils ont
survécu à trois guerres et ont été
bercés par le récit de plusieurs autres
maintenant il se croit prêt pour la
prochaine